go stay at the most expensive hotel and  where everybody stays at to kind of get  a feel wow this is kind of what it feels  like you got to do both and that is also  an investment you got it when I was poor  I had nothing to my name I wanted to go  rob elbows with Killers meaning like  people that were winning  and to kind of say this is what this  lifestyle looks like at Rodeo Drive  Beverly Hills Hotel this is what it  feels like at Montage this is what it  feels like at Pelican wow this is what  it feels like at the you know Pebble  Beach interesting okay cool I just spent  this money but damn I won more of this I  want my family to experience this what  if one day you're you're the question  becomes the what if one day when anytime  a sentence starts with what if one day  imagine if one day we need to spend more  using that sentence in 2022-2023 in a  positive way what if one day your dreams  do become a reality